Hi. Got a few things to work on today on
the agenda.
I think we're going to start with
uh the trajectory
level loss for diversity is all you need
to see if that gives us a nice
exploration
algorithm. We'll start with
that. Um there is some Cbinding work to
be done on the grid
environment. Probably do that next.
I need to do a little bit of work to see
if we can integrate new curriculum
learning stuff with
that and then we'll see where we go from
there. I think there's some debugging to
be done on the uh the new replay buffer
as well
because it works for some of the M. It
seems like it's fine for the simpler MS,
but something's weird with neural MMO.
It doesn't train anymore properly. So,
we'll have to figure that out.
Yeah, that is generally the plan for
today. I
have four or five hours right now to do
this and then very early dinner and then
uh back for another 2 three hours in the
evening. That is the agenda.
here, we had this like this weird
discriminator
thing. I don't even think this should be
part of the policy really.
of this thing right
here taking this out of the
policy. Oh, but then we have to
do Yeah, the optimizer gets fiddlier,
doesn't
it? The optimizer gets
fiddlier. All right. Well, we'll hard
code this size for now then because uh
we are going to have to mess with this
ice.
Okay, so here is the discriminator.
Uh we don't want these logs to
get unbashed
though and we want these logs to
be
structured. I'm just going to add them
to the state for now. as I go and just
wanted to ask why you consider Minecraft
not being a good environment for URL. I
think you mentioned some time ago. Okay.
Yeah. So, one and the biggest one is
it's really slow. Like really really
slow. Okay. Let's say that you were to
implement Minecraft like a thousandx
faster minimum, which you can actually
do. That's like actually a thing you
could do. Um, then you end up with the
problem of it's not good for tabular
rasa RL because there's not really like
a clear defined objective. Most of the
stuff that people do in Minecraft, uh,
they just do it because that's what they
do in the real world, right? Like
there's no reason to build a
house. Like you can kind of dig a hole
and you're good for the night and then
there's not really much advantage to
building a house. So you kind of just
end up with the mine portion, not the
craft portion. Um, and it turns into
like a much much simpler procedurally
generated adventure
game. It is really good for stuff like
the taskbased curriculum learning.
There's this really nice paper, this
like open AI paper on that uh where you
get diamonds just with a task
curriculum. But like that would have
been so much easier if the end were
fast. So, it's kind of got two horribly
bad things about it for that. Um,
probably you're better served by Net
Hack on both of those fronts. The only
thing Minecraft has going for it really
uh is that everybody knows Minecraft.
So, that that's pretty much it. Like, as
far as task go for RL intrinsically,
it's a very bad one.
And then the reason I don't use net hack
very often at all in my own work is yet
more infrastructure problems. It's very
difficult to run uh to run
multipprocessed or multi-threaded like
you can't run other way around. You
can't run a whole bunch of copies in the
same thread.
Infra is really king in
RL. Infra is king.
MS. Uh there's a guy that actually has a
version that's like somewhat faster that
he's releasing not as an RLM as a game
though. What's TPS ticks per
second? Okay, that's hilarious.
reimplementation?
Oh, yeah. That's not going to work.
Sorry, my guy. That's just not going to
work ever.
Yeah, but you can't w you can't just
wrap the existing game. It's too
slow, isn't it? Yeah, it is wrapping the
existing game. It's not a It's not like
a from scratch
Minecraft. So, this thing here, the
statebased simulation for this is at
last count 1 7 million steps per second
on one CPU
core. Yeah. And this
is I mean this is like a real M. This is
not a
toy. Has an economy. You can buy and
sell stuff. There's a lot to
this. And like I didn't even do anything
special here. This is like pretty
unoptimized. just like plain keep it
simple C. There's no like fancy SIMD.
Like there's
nothing. It's just real
simple. Like these MS like this, this
will run over 50 million steps per
second. Very, very
fast. Now, that's a little bit overkill,
but you do need to be able to train at
hundreds of thousands
minimum. And it gets worse when you go
to multiGPU machines because if you if
you want to let's say oh well we'll just
scale it. Well if you scale to eight
GPUs you only have the CPUs on that
machine to provide the data. So now
congratulations you probably only have
like four cores maybe eight cores to
provide all your data for each
GPU. So speed is
king. Speed is king.
Honestly, I'd be way down to like I I
would be down to make ultra fast
Minecraft for RL if there were
like if doing that would also somehow
fund all the stuff that Puffer wants to
do. I would gladly do that. But there's
not really a use case for it.
stuff game through
RL. Yeah, you're not like there's just
no way that you're ever going to come up
with that
stuff. Like, think about it. Nobody ever
learns that on their own,
right? Like, everyone reads the
wiki. I I don't even think has any
person ever beaten that game
blind. There's like unintuitive stuff
that you have to be told to do,
right? Like you need the end like you
need to go get the blaze rods and the
eyes of like to make the eyes of ender
to put in the stronghold portal,
right? Yeah, that's a rough one.
Net hack has similar stuff to it, but I
don't think that bad. That one's really
bad. That one's
tough. And the thing is like even if you
do that, like Minecraft is not a hard
game for a person to beat either.
You still can't do it with the way
like you need more breadcrumbs than you
have
basically. I mean I say that but then
again Pokemon did work right? We beat
Pokemon.
So, but it's it still required a lot of
fiddling and hacking with
stuff. We want stuff to work with way
less fiddling and way less hacking.
What I call this thing batch logic. What
we're doing right now is actually kind
of a cool exploration thing. So this is
diversity is all you need. Well, my
variant of it, uh, we're trying to get
we're trying to get one model to be able
to conditionally do different things,
uh, by training a
discriminator that looks at, uh,
trajectory segments and tries to tell if
agents are doing different
things without any guidance through PRL.
This
impossible, it's because people don't
solve the thing top of the Ross either.
So, there's this really cool paper, I
think from Pulkit's group where uh you
can just screw up all the graphics in
Atari, right? You can just like swap all
the assets for random stuff that doesn't
make sense and people won't be able to
learn how to play that at all, right?
But the RL agents will just learn it as
if it's the normal
game. So, this is the thing that people
forget, right? When it's like, oh, well,
it's hard to it takes so many frames to
learn this game or it's like this. No,
no, no, no. like you're overindexing on
how much people already know going into
it. Like you can make the problem
impossible for
humans and the RL agent will just do it
like nothing's
wrong. That's the cool thing with
RL. It's super human at
learning. At least a certain type of
learning.
Oh, come on. I had to reboot the
drivers and then we're going to get this
trajectory segment stuff
done. What I'm doing here is I'm going
to swap the
The current model just looks at the
logics of the current action. I'm going
to give it the logics of the full
trajectory or the full trajectory
segment rather.
called? Right. So, we don't need
this. I want to remove this reward
component so it's only called during
training. I don't think you need a
reward.
in. 256
in. Uh, that seems fine to
Uh, I'm going to just slice it for now
and then we'll clean this
up. Yeah, I'm going to just slice it for
Yeah, that's just as fast, if not faster
than
before. Does this do immediately
better? I don't think so.
See, the loss is so low on
this that it makes me think it's kind of
cheating. The loss is so low that it
makes me think it's cheating.
you? Maybe you
do, but you can't do divide by standard
deviation.
I think we're definitely going to want
something of this form. So, it makes
sense to go ahead and like fix up the
code to support this.
It's still definitely able to just
immediately know
though. So I don't think it's actually
doing anything because it's too easy.
It's too easy for the
discriminator. Discriminator is trying
to figure out which like you essentially
give it. You say you're policy one,
you're policy two, you're policy three,
you're policy four. And the
discriminator is supposed to look at
which is doing which based on its
behavior. But the thing is it has access
to the logic distribution because you
need that in order to back prop. And I
think it's like using some weird signals
in the
logits to figure it out instead of like
actually looking at the actions.
And I don't like you could technically
learn it with RL, but you shouldn't have
Let's at least clean this up so that
it's like more feasible
uh to do this.
need, we kind of need a way to know
which ID is assigned to which agent,
right?
Yeah, that's mildly annoying. Okay, I'm
going to actually have to think about
this to figure out how we do this
correctly.
Maybe really don't need to record the
batch at all.
Maybe we look at this problem
first. Why it's so easy for it to learn
this?
Okay, it literally hasn't even hit
anything
loss. It has this learned like
perfectly, right?
One, two, two,
three. One, two,
two. So one, two, two, three. Yeah. And
then
zero and
33 33. Yeah. So it has to sl perfectly
somehow. So the loss is actually it's
correct.
literally with this. It's still doing
it.
31 3. Literally, it just has the batch
logic.
Wait, wait.
April 10th,
106. Yeah, that must be from
now. Wait,
06. Hang on. Is that
I'm not sure if that's the correct
one. I thought there was something off
about that.
Maybe that's what happened before. Maybe
I wasn't loading the models and I
thought I
was do a quick run of
this. So this is you only get to
distinguish the policy from the first
logic.
doing? We should see vertical
separation.
You need like a harder objective for the
thing if you want something
that's really visually obvious. I think
perfectly good policy, but it doesn't
tell us very much on its
also isn't there
um there four policies, not two,
right? Yeah.
right. So we do like this, right? So we
do math
fifth. Do
this. Now you only get to see the logic
of your most selected.
loss. At least maybe we get something
interesting.
Let's run this for a
bit. We're basically we're trying to
create a scenario where like the snakes
get forced to go to different spots or
whatever.
really hard to tell these things
apart. So, this could just not even be
an algorithm failure, right? This could
just be like
a interpretability fail.
Now it only gets to see the logic of the
first action.
might learn based on the zero state to
uh well, we'll
see. I'm curious to see what this does.
They don't seem particularly predisposed
to any one direction, do they?
I'm just trying to figure out some way
to like give this thing a weak signal.
Yeah. So I think before it was abusing
the fact that it was start of episode to
just like take one action. It's these
things are like very very good at
cheating information if you let them.
There's still some entropy in this as
well,
The white and the gray ones are
definitely going pop, aren't
they? For the most
part, that
separation. The red ones are going to
the right. Yeah, this is it. We got
it almost. It's like It's very
on. I mean, this is like this is very
close to the result that we were going
for, right?
How is it telling apart the gray
ones? Maybe it
isn't. Well, the red ones are clearly
closer to the right.
Yeah, the white and the gray are not
perfectly separated yet, I
right? The key is they also they've
learned non-trivial separable policy.
They didn't just learn to go that way
and crash into a wall. They're still
taking into account the reward.
heavy-handed. The loss is low, but uh I
think it's crashed the policies a bunch.
We'll look at the policy regardless.
This one might just be the straight go
left, go right, whatever.
Yeah. So, that's very close to
separation, but the policy just isn't
high enough quality to be able to uh to
tell. We'll try like
this. I just want to get like a clear
demo of this doing the thing that you
expect. And it's very close to that
already.
I'd take like a 50
score cleanly separated one.
this
40. That's at least passable, right?
Like this should be good enough to
evaluate.
uh I should make the roll outs like skip
the first thousand frames or whatever.
Let's do that real quick because this
this runs way faster than it renders.
policy is just slightly too weak.
Right. Okay, we'll go back to the
original. It It's sensitive to this
scale for
sure. Definitely sensitive to this
Maybe we can even get something. Maybe
this is even too aggressive, right?
Maybe the trick is to find something
that is
distinguishable without hurting the
Try a couple
things. We go to
25. We give it longer segment maybe.
There's definitely separation. It's just
not as clean as you would
want. Also, the policies are not you're
like you're harming the policies quite a
bit. Okay. Okay, what if we give it the
let's what if we stop trying to make it
so difficult on it, right? We give it
access
to the full log
prompts of the action it
selects. Basically, it just gets to know
the actions that it selects.
Okay. So this is very close to the uh
the performance of the original policy
without this
objective and with a
very reasonable loss.
tell? You can't really tell them apart.
The model can tell them apart, but I
can't.
I don't see a clear directional bias at
any of
[Music]
You don't really see
it. I don't really see
it. According to the model, these guys
are playing differently, but we can't
really tell.
What happens when we increase the number
of agents or the number of
policies? If I try to do like
H still tell them apart.
Yeah. So, it's definitely harder for it
to learn.
Crazy how easy it is for the model to
distinguish
trajectories. Do you just train it with
a bunch of dropout or
something? I guess that's a thing we
could do.
harder. Is it still just going to crush
this
with 4.8 drop out?
I think that the gray and the white Let
me Let me just check what colors
are. So,
it's
red and Yeah. Okay. So, these are paired
correctly.
buffer box
ISP whatever it's still
okay that's all the agenda for today
then captain
um I'm trying to think what the hell do
you even do about that is the
thing because I'm pretty sure it's the
network
But I will have to go down to those
machines in person today
then. Yeah, I'm trying to get separable
policies here.
I think this is
something I'm trying to figure out. So
the problem is that the uh the neural
net is really good at figuring out which
policies
are different from one another. Like
really good at figuring it out.
I'm pretty sure that the white and gray
are way more vertical and the uh red and
pink are way more horizontal in this
one.
X buffer refactor is done for now.
Uh, it needs
testing because I think that there's
still some things screwy with
right now. Can't even access block two.
Could this
morning? I'm trying to think what I
should do about it.
I mean, I can go reset the network. That
didn't help for [ __ ] last
time. Well, maybe it was tail scale. I
think we figured
out I think we figured out maybe it's
tail
scale. Yeah, cuz you SSH in fine here
and then it just
stalls.
Having issues on the box itself though.
What do you
Uh, would that go through tail
scale? That shouldn't I don't think that
should go through tail scale.
It shouldn't go through tail scale. It's
very possibly the network.
Are you on a different network?
Yes. The boxes have their own
network. I mean, so that would be a I
mean, that would suggest that it's not
tail scale, right? My box is fine.
up. I think it's got to be
The thing that I don't
understand is
like
okay. See, now it doesn't let me SSH. I
just got to the box. It accessed just
fine and then it didn't and then it just
stopped. So I think it's just shitty
intermittent crashing
ISP. It says the boxes are connected
though, all of
go? Need the actual IP a bit. Hello,
welcome.
Leave this thing up in the background
while I debug these network issues real
quick.
Okay, I've got
um got this
thing. I'm not a network guy. Losing
packets is bad though.
shitty. All right, I'm going to paste a
few things into Gro like a [ __ ] See if
I can debug it real quick. If not, I'm
going to have to like finish up this
work session and then go out there to uh
to debug
because I don't know what else we do
with this.
Just wanted to let you know. Well, I
know. It's just like I'm trying to
figure out what the hell to do with it.
It's a really weird
situation. I'm not exactly a network
guy.
Wait, what the hell? It's just
generating random
crap. I pasted an image back and it
generates. Okay, it just generated
like weird garbage.
Is it going to keep trying to generate
That does.
I'm going to see if this works. I'm only
going to spend a couple more minutes on
this though right
now and then I'm going to just go back
to this for a little bit.
How do I get the router IP? The local IP
of the router.
Okay. Isn't that just local host or am I
stupid?
It's weird cuz it's like suddenly fast
and then it like just locks up.
up.
Lovely. All right. I think I'm going to
have to actually go out to the machines
in person to actually run anything on
these because uh yeah, this just doesn't
respond from here. So, I will do
that. But uh I want to finish this
research block up first.
since we have some folks here and this
is kind of potentially cool here.
So, we have these two that look like
they're going down and these two that
are going
me I uh if it's RL specifically the
quick start guide on puffer.ai AI is my
general set of recommendations for
newcomers for general ML like
CS231N. The videos for that are online.
Okay. And let's see. Did this give us
the same thing as
before? Yeah. So, this is
similar. We've got
right? So that's what happens if you
really crank up the drop
out. If you don't crank the dropout,
it's hard to distinguish them,
right? Or no.
retrain. The goal of all of this is to
come up with
um algorithm that gets you visually
distinguishable policies.
What if I just set the coefficient? Hang
on. What if I set the coefficient to
one, but then I make it really easy?
Does that do anything? What if I set
this plus coefficient to
one? Uh, but
easier. That might be too hard still.
We'll see.
slowly. I'll look at this. policy. Then
I'll try without dropout and then I'll
try something completely different
because this is uh too much over
optimizing on something that only half
works. I mean that should be a mostly
okayish policy. 50
Oh, yeah. I mean, that's distinguishable
now for sure,
right? But I'm a little unsure how
um there's supposed to be four
distinguishable policies and I can only
really tell apart two.
archive. Oh, that's my
bad. Yeah, that's my bad right there.
Let's run
this. Yeah. So, there we go.
Um, that's actually perfect, isn't
it? Look, they're literally each
separated to one side.
what happens without the uh the dropout
now is my
question. Why is
having Oh, I just saw your thing. Why is
having different policies that do
different things beneficial?
Uh the idea is that if you can get
policies to do like distinguishably
different things, then a you potentially
help break weird self-play dynamics and
b you also potentially get a general
purpose exploration that should be way
better than entropy
bonus. It might be too easy without
dropout.
You still get a lot of it here,
right? These guys are still going here.
These guys are going over
here. These guys are going over here.
and gray. I don't know how gray and red
are different,
but yeah, that's still definitely doing
something. Now, what happens if you give
it the full distribution again?
Because right now we're not giving it uh
we've got like this
mask. What if we do
this? This might be way too easy.
It's also the only one that hasn't
really hurt the policy a bunch though
cuz this is pretty much on par with the
original baseline
If I run this just the eval. They end up
in the same
spot. I see a lot of red up top and a
lot of white and gray down
You can't back You can't back propagate
through observations though.
Yeah, that's where you would have to add
like a
reward. I prefer not to do
What else could we use for this other
than the full action trajectory like
this?
Okay, let me just write this out because
it'll be more interesting to watch and
maybe we'll figure something
out. So, what I'm trying to figure out
here, right?
You're in like a
state. You get an
observation and then you take an action
and then you go to your next state, take
your next
action,
right? And these go into your neural
net, which is going to be an LSTM. So
you have, you know, your memory that
goes like this.
And ideally we'd like to
do well what we're doing right now is
we're just taking these three
actions and we're saying hey if you look
at the actions of one
policy
pi
a and then you look at pi
2 of
a. Are you a PhD? Yes.
Pi 2 of A. Then can you tell these two
apart? Right? You feed these into a
discriminator and you try to predict
uh you feed these into like a
discriminator D and you try to predict
one, right? And
here you feed these into D and you try
to predict two. You're basically just
trying to predict based on the actions.
you're trying to predict which policy it
came
from. Now, the problem with this, right,
is if you're predicting based on the
series of
actions, you fall into uh the trap of
like the agent can just jitter in a
specific way, right? like any way that
the agent has to communicate what policy
it is to the discriminator, it will use.
So if you encode it in the action, it
can just be, oh yeah, policy one does
the same thing as policy 2, except it
jitters a little bit this way. Or, you
know, policy 2 does the same thing, but
it jitters a little bit that way. So
it's really not a robust mechanism for
encouraging policies to learn something
that is meaningfully different.
I guess what we would want to do, right,
is what we'd want to do is take like
discriminator S and then
S2, which would in general be SN. So the
first and the last state of a
segment. This would be a pretty strong
signal.
There would still be some cases where
the agent could cheat it. Um, if there's
like for instance, if there's any flag
that the agent can
set in the observations, then it could
just like set a flag or
whatever. But a lot of the time, this
should be more robust.
This should be more
robust. The problem is I don't know how
we actually optimize this because state
two doesn't directly depend on the
policy and state doesn't directly depend
on the policy. Right? These are inputs.
So we would have to optimize this with
reinforcement
learning which you know obviously we're
all set up for reinforcement learning
already but it's so much better when we
don't have to
add more reinforcement learning for
auxiliary loss
better. I don't think we can put like
the encoding of the state either. Like
if we instead use the hidden vector for
the state, then it'll just set the
hidden vector to like just tell you what
what policy you're in, right? What
policy it is.
Heck, it's probably already doing that
in the logits to some extent, right?
Which is why we tried to like normalize
them. What's some good way that we can
deal with this? like how's a good way to
what is a good way to deal with
this? I can definitely do it with
reinforcement learning. I just really
prefer not to.
What if we if we also give it the state?
Is there any indirect indirect way that
it learns to get to better
state? No, there's literally no gradient
path, right?
So this is the that is the tricky
part. That is the tricky part I
guess is figuring out how to add this to
the loss.
Yeah, it's tough when like you only have
the actions to work off
of. That's still probably better than
entropy, isn't
it? Distinguishable action
I guess maybe with dropout it's harder
to learn
jitter. It's still pretty brittle
though. It's still pretty
brittle. Yeah.
we we can definitely train the
discriminator. That's not the issue. I
know how to train a good discriminator
on this.
Like you can train this discriminator,
right? The problem is it won't affect
the action distrib distribution at all.
Is there an obvious solution here other
than just use reinforcement learning for
this part as
well? Like I could technically do this
with reinforcement learning, right?
The way that you would do this with pure
RL, right? So you train a discriminator
on the first and the last steps of the
trajectory segment. If the discriminator
gets it right, then you add a report.
It's not
terrible. It's not terrible.
Technically, it's also not that
difficult to implement. I
think it shouldn't be that slow
network? I don't know if you would share
the
network. You could share the comp
layers. I
guess you could also fully separate
them. I think it's worth trying. Let me
commit this version for now.
Okay. So, the discriminator is going to
be a little bit more complex now,
right?
Discriminator going to be something like
this.
All
right, here's your new
discriminator. Then we'll just do death
rim.
And we're going to have to fiddle with
this a little
bit. I'm going to have to do that
interactively. But the way that we want
to implement this
now needs to move. Actually, several
things kind of need to move around. Huh.
tricky. You have to recmp compute the
advantages, don't you?
well. There needs to be a no reduction,
right? Reduction equal none.
right, we'll try this. This is a mess,
but we will try
this. I'm going to have
to steer a little bit here, I think.
Oops. Let me get this implemented and
then I'll explain the
idea. I need to at least get the uh the
initial version. Shouldn't take long.
So, the model
works and I just have to figure out this
weird shaping stuff.
Does it make sense to add it to the end
of the trajectory
only? I
no. Yeah, this is just like a bunch of
silly hacking to get this to
work. We'll be able to clean this up a
lot. Okay, that's the kernel compiled.
This should not be slow if we've done
this correctly because this
adds like 132 of the amount of compute.
Yeah, this is a tiny amount of
compute. Okay.
The problem is this loss is not
decreasing at all. So it doesn't know
now. It doesn't know what to
do. So why is
that? Oh, wait. This should be minus.
That's the
difference. I think it's just cuz that
loss would have exploded if it had any
either this is dramatically harder to
learn which it is but like not learnable
at all is a little bit suspicious uh
or I have the reward implemented wrong.
So the idea here is that you
give you give this discriminator
uh the first observation of a segment
and the last observation of a segment.
And if the discriminator can tell which
policy
uh those two observations came
from then the policy gets a reward. So
basically the policy wants to act
differently from the other
policies. That's the goal.
signal. That loss is still stuck
though. We are optimizing it, right?
loss plus
equal
coefficient times
loss and here loss plus
equals and this is not inside of like a
noat or something
dumb. You know this is this is correct
but
uh guess it's tricky.
It's also possible I've just massively
screwed up the reward computation,
right?
do if I suspect I screwed something up
here as a first
approximation, I can just do this.
Uh let me think where I add
it. I have to add it
shape. How's this 128?
Thanks. No, something's wrong with
that. Oh, wait.
and that still wouldn't do it. It should
be
it. Yeah, that's the tough
part. That is the tough part.
I might need to just add it to the
uh the actual advantage calculation.
Right?
It's got to be a better way of doing
this. It's a really hard signal to learn
from.
I do this like a
filtering. That's probably just going to
break it, right?
is is the first and last state really
what you want anyways I think it
is there's no other good way to encode
like interesting stuff happened in the
middle
Hey. Okay. What's like the most correct
way I can implement
this? I guess it would is a
pre-processing step
do
that. And then down
here we do the
uh we do this maybe
distinguishable. It's kind of nice. I
guess you don't have to tune this loss
coefficient anymore. You do have to
still tune the
uh reward coefficient, though. I think
it gives you one extra reward
coefficient to tune.
Now, I don't think there's anything you
can distinguish.
But it's really not that much
better. See, now the difficult thing
with the reward is you
optimization. So this doesn't help.
If I
do if I do this, I think then it knows
the uh trajectory, but it screws up the
policy.
still only knows it uh 30% of the time.
Even with this
really Okay, so that score is really
low for screwing up the policy.
this.
Well, it's only two. I need to move on
to the next thing soon, but I'm going to
try one last thing. I'm going to just
clean up. There's one thing I wasn't too
sure about.
I want to clean up.
I think that actually should be enough
to fix that one
problem. Prevent it from uh
changing mid trajectory.
Okay, that does actually improve the
results quite a bit.
Like, is that seriously it though? This
is as good as it
Let's see if we give it like every 16th
frame.
here. Accuracy goes way up
though. Yeah, it's definitely too big a
reward magnitude.
Yeah, but now we're down back down to it
not being able to figure anything out.
So, it's very sensitive. It
seems it's just not getting that reward
at all.
Well, we're just going to run this for
50 mil if uh if this crashes because
this is about what we wanted.
Okay, that's about as good as we're
going to get, I think, today on this.
This
is Well, let's at least see what the
result looks
like. Apparently, this half of the
trajectories can tell what the model is.
because they have like a very strong
directional bias. It's funny.
It's actually they're not just going in
one direction though. They're all going
in both of the directions, right?
That got almost the same reward
though as before, didn't it?
The problem is you're going to you screw
up the trajectories. It's really
gets all that reward and it can still
only tell it apart half the time.
Yeah, see the scores crashed to 50.
Okay, we're going to leave this thing
alone for now.
definitely feels like we're on to
something here. It's
just it's tricky because the actionbased
version you can learn directly um but
it's very easy to
exploit and um
the observationbased
one is hard to exploit, but it's very
hard to learn because you don't have a
direct gradient
signal. 2
p.m. I'm going to grab a
drink. I'm going to take a few minutes
to clear my
head. I am then we're going to work on C
binding stuff, I think, for
puffer. So, uh, puffer grid environment
needs a C binding. We need to come up
with some new API stuff for that.
There's quite a bit to do there.
I think it's very likely that there's
some form of this that works
though. There should be some form of
this.
Uh there should be some form of this
that works. I would
expect All
num ends. Num maps map size max map
size.
right? Yeah, the only thing here is max
actions, rewards,
terminals, impact from
occasions. And you don't need
this. All you need is max map
size and that'll be fine.
max map
size. You do open it
grid. That's about
it. Now there's all this state
You get to delete all this and you just
need this drop.
Now return length four and you need
float N, right?
this. Is there a tick on
this? Watch. Hi, Spencer. I'm adding the
binding stuff to the maze and then
figuring out how to do some fancy level
setting stuff, which will be applicable
to uh the driving sim as
well. I'm also pretty close to having
the dev branch cleaned up nicely. Uh
there's still some testing to be done
and I know that a bunch of the machines
are a mess. So, I got to finish this and
go figure out what the heck is wrong
with
machines. Much work to be done
generally.
done. Uh, yeah, there's no tick. So, I
got to add a tick.
decided to switch my ops to exactly
match
NYU. That's
good. Can do that and then we can always
optimize from
there. mainly last few days I've just
been trying to ignore as much noise as
possible and just get stuff done on this
new uh new branch of
code. There's like a lot of algorithm
stuff floating around that's like close
but not quite there, you know?
looking at ways to optimize my grid
cap. I think it'll become a
bottle when we start resampling from
more maps. It could very well
be. I'm really going to just need to sit
down with you at some point and like
really dig into this thing. What is the
current state of uh of the training? Can
you like train on multiple maps or
what's the what's the current
256 simultaneous
660k entity encoder takes 3 to four
minutes to set up the cache in a net.
It should wait. Struggles on
learning when collisions were added only
got to 70ish% solve
rate. Okay. Yeah, it should definitely
solve single map collisions, multi maps.
Okay. Yeah. So, definitely figure out
that once you have that set up, I think
I mean that's pretty close to like being
able to replace the original
SIM. I think when you have that, we'll
have to do some optimization and stuff,
but that's pretty
close. Yeah, we should chat about some
stuff at some point soon. I'm trying to
be around more in the evenings, but I've
also just been streaming a
ton last few days.
Want to get fully solved first. 10 to 15
XP.
Yep. Next week should be last week for
construction anyways. Then I'll have
full time to work on this. Perfect.
Because I might have even more stuff for
you to do.
this? Meeting a fun robotics company.
pitch him some RL stuff.
Awesome. So, one of the things and we
should chat about this type of stuff.
Um, one of the things I'm thinking could
be a good way to
uh bring Puffer into industry that you
actually might want to be a part of as
well. Uh, would be to just like make
some like really solid Sims for specific
domains. Like they actually They have to
look like that as well. So, like you
know the robot warehouse sim that you
made like what if that
sim were rendered to look like actual
robot warehouse and you know maybe we
made it either or like finer disc dis
discretized so it looks continuous right
that would make a huge difference like
the dynamics of that environment are not
that far off of actually like being a
warehouse you
thing. Yeah. But I think generally
longer term making it really easy to
build Sims is going to be is going to be
nice.
Need to make terminals.
Observations, actions, rewards,
terminal, truncations, nums. You forgot
numbs and seed.
And pretty much all this should be like
the
same as
uh as
before, right? This should all kind of
not change very much.
it. Now that's just fixing other random
stuff from dev.
default? No, we should have
uh shouldn't be using the default
policy.
welcome. Oh, wait. This should be
red. No.
I think I probably just changed the
API. Yes, that no longer returns
that you have one error.
There is going to be uh there will be
many errors. I'm
sure they need to be
go. Now, this still isn't going to
work. It'll
run, but I don't think we're going to
get much back from this.
And uh now we have to figure out
the map loading and saving and all of
that stuff and how we're going to deal
with
it. That is the main thing.
So this is one of the environments where
we have a fair bit of stuff in the
site and the main thing is that uh it
creates these
states and then these states get shared.
I could do like a global in it or
whatever.
The thing is this gets called every time
reset gets called in this code which is
hard to do.
Let me look at how Aaron uh needs to use
this as
well. I should be able to get this code.
One
second. So Aaron has been working on
curriculum learning in Puffer.
tricky. Let me see how the sampling
works.
levels. And then when you call step give
itself
levels. So I think it is just like a
random is it random uniform over these
levels? I think it
Oh, and then these levels have a
probability or
whatever. No, it looks like he was
experimenting with cumulative problem,
but now it's just a random choice over
levels. Either way, we can support
something like that, I think.
I mean really all you need is a shared
net.
I'm trying to think if that's good
enough.
potentially. I can just give
you like shared create function or
everything. No, I think that covers
everything.
Everything.
Yeah, you'll need a way to unpack
different data types. That's not
hard. You just need a shared create
Okay. Well, I've got uh a little bit of
time to start on this right now. And uh
we'll finish this after dinner most
likely. Very early dinner today. But I
think I have a little time to start on
this. So, the idea is
pass. Why does this take arcs like this?
Empty
this. This actually needs an
implementation.
whatsoever. You just need this extra
function. I
And this doesn't even
unpack doesn't unpack the end at all.
Right. Yeah, this doesn't unpack the end
of it all. This is just going to call
your
code. Uh, this needs quartz though,
doesn't
it? Yeah, this does need
quartz. Hang on.
Right. So you have to unpack
anything. No,
nothing. Uh you literally just call your
function from this.
object. How do we do it when we uh
create the end? I think it's going to be
the same as
You need to know the type of object this
is going to
Oh, we don't want to overwrite the
error. Maybe it's literally just
this. This seems really pointless to do
it this way, though, doesn't
it? Like when you can literally just do
this.
So we
args and
quarks. And then you could do something
like
It's literally just that, isn't
it? You just define this thing.
Yeah. And then this gets defined over
it,
right? So you get rid of
this. Then you just bind
this. Let's see if we can get that to
run.
by. All right, that's uh yeah, I got to
go grab food. I will be back in about an
hour and uh goal will be finish
this some additional testing on some
other stuff, various miscellaneous dev.
Hopefully getting to cluster maintenance
as well today. lot of stuff to do but
good progress overall. So for the few
folks watching
um puffer.ai for all my stuff start the
GitHub to help us out. You can join the
discord to get involved with dev. This
is all open source contributor.